rated M for Mature  loyalty can be such a hard pain to  define you are a girl from the north  here in service to lady Marjorie if your  loyalties were to become conflicted  between your king and the very person  whom you serve what would you do then  I would be true to the king your grace  Duncan Ryland  this house needs you both but you can  only choose one my lord  Duncan total you will be my Sentinel  taco this is reckless  you  you want to kill me don't you prove how  strong you are  do it for evening  your little brother had bigger balls  than you now that bow humility Getty  runs off me you can aware me  wah drink enough that's enough  ah Roderick the gate will fall without  one of us holding it advance one of us  has to stay  let me save your life on our house iron  from ice problem iron from ice  I'll hold them off Roderick go  next time on Game of Thrones  trail  Gregor and Fiona  or Nassau gurbin